und ich begrüße jetzt Alexander Kissler
von der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung NZZ in
Berlin eine Woche Streik und die
Umfragen des Kanzlers sind im Keller
Olaf Scholz wie fest sitzt er ihrer
Meinung nach nach Meinung der
Journalistin und Journalisten in Berlin
noch im Sattel ja schön guten Morgen die
Frage kann natürlich ernsthaft nur die
regierende Ampel i beantworten es sind
drei Partner die fast auf gedei und
Verderb aneinander gekettet sind
angesichts parallel sinkender Umfrage
und Zustimmungswerte man singt zu Boden
und wer zuerst abspringt ist vielleicht
auch als erster dann am Boden angekommen
deshalb wird die Macht dieses Bündnis
noch etwas eininanderschweißen aber
gerade in diesem super Wahljahr mit
einer erhitzten Bevölkerung einer
gestiegenen Beteiligung Bereitschaft
öffentlich Protest einzulegen ist nun
wirklich die Ampel gefragt auf
protestierende zuzugehen gehen und zu
zeigen ja wir haben verstanden ja wir
sind zu einer Änderung unseres politiks
Stils bereit das haben die aber wenn ich
das richtig in Erinnerung habe schon vor
einem Jahr ziemlich genau auch schon mal
gesagt nun würde ich jetzt gerne noch
mal vielleicht auf eine ganz aktuelle
Situation eingehen nämlich die SPD
Fraktionsklausur die findet ja seit
gestern und eben auch heute noch in
Berlin statt ganz spannt der Kanzler war
gestern für 90 Minuten angekündigt war 3
Stunden dann wohl vor Ort und am Ende
gab es nur so eine ganz kurzem
Mitteilung von Frau esken es war ein
konstruktives Gespräch was glauben Sie
was ist dabei rausgekommen ja das
Verhältnis zwischen dem Bundeskanzler
und seiner Bundestagsfraktion ist
erheblich belastet aus ganz handfesten
materiellen Gründen angesichts der
umfrageerte muss ja mindestens ein
Drittel der momentanen Parlamentarier im
Bundestag um sein Mandat fürchten das
heißt es geht dort wirklich um eine
macht fast schon um eine Existenzfrage
und momentan an hat der Kanzler eben
selbst verchuldet wie ich finde ein so
schlechtes Image dass viele Bundesbürger
nicht mal ein verstimmeltes Brot von ihm
annehmen würden und es kommt nun
wirklich oder es käme nun wirklich auf
den Kanzler an er kann allerdings aus
seiner emotionalen verpanzerung nicht
heraus die Gabe der Empathie ist imm
offenbar öffentlich zumindest nicht in
die Wiege gelegt insofern ist es
gewissermaßen ein Dilemma die SPD
Fraktion kann jetzt nicht im Rahmen
einer laufenden Legislatur den Kanzler
wechseln das ist undenkbar allerdings
sich vorzustellen ähm mit dem fast schon
depressiven Gesicht von Herrn Scholz in
einen Wahlkampf zu ziehen sind auch
keine guten Aussichten das heißt es wird
dort nach wie vor ein Fingerhakeln geben
zwischen Bundeskanzleramt und SPD
Fraktion gibt es denn in der SPD
überhaupt eine personelle Alternative
die Bildzeitung die hat ja mal gesagt ja
der pisturius der sei ja so wahnsinnig
beliebt der könnte es machen aber der
hat natürlich auch jetzt nicht unbedingt
die Hausmacht um mit einmal Kanzler zu
werden die Hausmacht hat er nicht
vielleicht überschätzt er sich da auch
etwas mit mit seinen landesministerellen
Erfahrungen aus Niedersachsen die er
bisher nur hatte man müsste ja auch die
die Linke SPD die ja doch recht wichtig
ist hinter sich bringen man müsste die
usos hinter sich bringen die glaube ich
mit Herrn Pistorius nicht sehr viel
gemein hat also diese neue Disparatheit
der SPD die ja nach dem Einzug in den
Bundestags festgestellt worden ist also
sehr viel junge dabei auch viele die
doch programmatisch sehr links gestrickt
sind diese Disparatheit trägt dazu bei
dass man sich kaum auf einen konsensual
neuen Gegenkandidaten wird einigen
können also bis zum Ende dieser
Legislatur wann immer die sein wird wird
man mit Herrn Scholz als Bundeskanzler
leben müssen wenn wir uns mal die
Parteienlandschaft anschauen heute
morgen gab es ja im ZDF Politbarometer
eine neue Umfrage wie es um die
möglichen Wahlergebnisse bei einer
Bundestagswahl gebe die sogenannte
Sonntagsfrage da sieht man die SPD im
Keller die Union die heute ihre
Vorstandsklausur hat die profitiert aber
nicht so richtig wirklich liegt schon
seit Monaten immer so so um die 30% mal
ein Prozentpunkt drüber mal drunter
woran liegt das na gut ist natürlich
einerseits ein ganz starker
Aufwärtstrend gegenüber diesem
desaströsen Ergebnis unter lasch der
letzten Endes natürlich der falsche
Kandidat gewesen ist also März macht
schon auch einiges richtig das muss man
sagen klar ist natürlich auch dass für
die Unzufriedenheit es mittlerweile
verschiedene Ventile gibt bündnissara
Wagenknecht das jetzt ja auch durchaus
bürgerliche teilweise ansprechen kann
ist bei 4% glaube ich
demnächst will die werteunion vielleicht
zu einer Partei werden und die die AFD
als eine Partei mit eben durchaus auch
systemkritischen und scharfen
Oppositionellen Tönen äh greift
natürlich zu auf das wachsende Milieu
der fundamental unzufriedenen und da ist
natürlich sehr schwierig für Herrn März
einerseits was er ja behauptet und
teilweise auch tut konstruktiv
Opposition zu sein und andererseits zu
sagen mit uns würde es besser was wenn
auch seine Machtoption würde er wieder
eine große Koalition eingeben einer
gebeutelten SPD würde er die Grünen
versuchen ins Bett der Partnerschaft zu
bekommen das wäre auch schwierig hat die
Grünen ja als Hauptgegner in der
Bundesregierung identifiziert und da tut
sich natürlich eine fundamental
Opposition wie die AFD aber auch die das
Bündnis sarer Wagenknecht natürlich in
der Opposition erst einmal leichter
Konturen zu gewinnen sie haben ja noch
nie regiert jetzt haben sie gerade eben
mal zwei eine Partei eine politische
Strömung an aufgegriffen und damit sind
wir eigentlich schon beim nächsten Thema
AFD und werteunion ähm wir hatten im
November letzten Jahres und das hat das
recherchenetzwerk Korrektiv in dieser
Woche äh herausgebracht ein Treffen in
Potzdam mit dabei
Neonazis Unternehmer AFD Politiker und
wohl auch zwei PolitikerInnen die der
werteunion zugeordnet werden ähm was äh
und der Verfassungsschutzpräsident hat
auch noch mal davor gewahnt vor einer
zunehmenden Gefahr von rechts haben wir
das ganze unterschätzt es ging ja bei
diesem Treffen um das sogenannt um dies
sogenannte Remigration also die
Abschiebung von Menschen teilweise auch
mit deutschenem Pass na die Abschiebung
von Menschen mit deutschen Pass geht
natürlich überhaupt nicht rechtlich
nicht moralisch nicht ethisch nicht ist
gegen das Grundgesetz ist ein Fall für
den Staatsanwalt wo wirklich die
Abschiebung die Deportation vielleicht
sogar die zwangsweise Ausschaffung von
Menschen mit deutschenem Pass gefordert
wird diese Recherche von Korrektiv lässt
andererseits natürlich auch gewisse
Fragen offen es gab mittlerweile
Äußerung in der Öffentlichkeit auch bei
uns in der NZZ von Teilnehmern die das
etwas anders berichten die sagen das ist
nur aus dem Zusammenhang teilweise
gerissen worden es wurde abgehört wird
behauptet würde verzert dargestellt ich
weiß es nicht ich war nicht dabei es
bleiben noch einige Fragen offen
Korrektiv will nur Material nachlegen
allerdings im Rahmen einer
Theateraufführung das halte ich für das
untaugliche Mittel auch der
ursprüngliche Text hatte für mich zu
viel theaterdner war ja nach Art eines
schauermärchens mit eingebauten
Gruseleffekten aufgebaut gleich wohl
wenn es sich so abgespielt haben sollte
was ich nicht weiß aber wenn es wirk
wirklich genauso abgespielt haben sollte
dann haben wir natürlich ein Problem
dass legitime Kritik an der
gegenwärtigen Migrationspolitik in
radikale bis extremistische
Aufforderungen zum Handeln an die
Politik übergehen kann da genau ist die
Grenze wo es extremistisch wird radikale
Meinungen sind unschön aber noch nicht
verboten wir müssen genau hinschauen wo
wird es extremistisch und da muss die
scheiderlinie scharf gezogen werden
Alexander Kissler von der Neuen Zürcher
Zeitung herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung heute morgen hier bei
Phönix vielen herzlichen Dank
meinerseits